foule en liesse et et à bucarest tout à
l'heure toute la journée la capitale
roumaine a été le théâtre de ces scènes
inimaginables il ya encore quelques
heures une foule en liesse parce qu'un
dictateur nicolae ceausescu a été arrêté
après s'être enfui parce que en se
soulevant le peuple roumain a mis fin en
quelques heures
à 24 ans de terreur et de souffrance la
fin du régime ceausescu en roumanie
c'est un événement historique que nous
vous faisons vivre depuis ce matin et
c'est pourquoi les programmes d'antenne
dont été modifiées aussitôt après ce
journal
vous pourrez suivre un magazine animé
par daniel bilalian sur les événements
roumanie images reportages témoignages
sur l'un des événements majeurs de cette
fin de siècle ceausescu est donc arrêtée
mais tout n'est pas réglé en roumaine
l'insurrection populaire n'a pas encore
vaincu en effet des éléments toujours
fidèles au dictateur résiste à bucarest
mais aussi dans d'autres villes
alors la situation est elle en train de
basculer
philippe le faut l'histoire un nouveau
la danse et images que nous venons juste
de recevoir d'une libération en marche
voici la première preuve par l'image que
l'armée s'est bien rallier avec ces
manifestants par dizaines sur un tank
dans la principale artère de bucarest la
roumanie la rue mag et rue ils sont des
centaines de milliers ce matin alors que
les étudiants avaient appelé à
manifester que qu'ils ont été relayés
dans la journée par les ouvriers en
grève et l'ensemble de la population
il crée ne détruisons pas les preuves du
crime
autrement dit nadim en pas ce cap et
ceausescu il faut que ces preuves
témoigne pour l'histoire
nous sommes ici au centre de bucarest
sur la place de la république devant
l'ancien palais royal devenu siège du
parti
les manifestants ont investi le palais
et il jette par le balcon
les oeuvres complètes de chaouchi
secours
et la foule ils sont des centaines de
milliers reprend dehors le tyran à bas
le tyran c'est à ce moment que l'on
vient d'apprendre que ceausescu a tenté
de fuir
ils ont applaudi
et l'on voit les premières traces de ce
peuple libéré dans ces drapeaux dont le
centre a été trouée dont le centre a été
déchiré à coups de ciseaux avant il y
avait au milieu de ce drapeau un épi de
blé un fluide pétrole et le génie des
carpates
ici on va re la photo d'elena elena
c'est la femme de chaouch et ce coup et
on crie au crime
oui
compris à la liberté on dit ceausescu
sera jugé mais pour l'instant à 20h
heure française
rien n'est réglé la radio et la
télévision roumaine
on est à l'heure actuelle au centre de
bucarest de bataille féroce certains
témoins affirment avoir vu plusieurs
centaines de morts
voilà nous reviendrons tout au long de
ce journal sur les dernières
informations dès que nous aurons
d'autres dépêches sur ce qui se passe
donc à bucarest
une fois de plus la télévision a joué un
rôle capital dans cette page d'histoire
aujourd'hui en direct pendant plusieurs
heures des millions de roumains ont
assisté aux discussions de l'état major
du soulèvement
c'était dans les studios de la
télévision roumaine à bucarest
récit de cette révolution direct
jean-marc il use tout d'abord un studio
étriqué une atmosphère de réunions
syndicales
une petite foule qui se bousculent
maladroitement autour d'un micro et d'un
drop et pourtant c'est de ce studio de
la télévision roumaine que jailliront
après quarante deux ans de communisme
les premiers mots et les premières
images de liberté écoutez ne dit que la
roumanie socialiste dit la roumanie dans
les rues de bucarest les roumains n'en
croient pas leurs oreilles
la radio officielle vient de tomber et
c'est par la voix de mme hirsch et à
dinescu poète et surtout opposant
célèbre qu'ils apprennent que nicolae
ceausescu le tir ont détesté vient de
quitter le pouvoir
déjà une source diplomatique occidentale
affirme que l'ancien ministre déchu
cornelio manescu 63 ans aurait pris le
pouvoir à la tête d'un front de salut
national
confusion sur les écrans de télévision
occidentales le visage de cet homme
acteur célèbre de la télévision
officielle roumaine passera un instant
pour celui du nouveau numéro un
l'information est fausse mais l'émotion
est juste l'acteur né alors même pas sûr
de survivre à son geste de défi aux
autorités
peut-être allez-vous nous vaincre et dit
il peut-être allons-nous mourir
peut-être que tout à l'heure c'est même
caméra diffuseront de nouveau vous dise
pour 6 me mais regardez moi je les suis
ni dieu ni diable
je suis un simple rhume un humain je
vous êtes jure de me rejoindre ici à la
télévision
comment l'amérique latine est bénévole
et on dépit des 20 cours de la nuit et
des mitrailleuses de la milice qui
claquent sans cordon bucarest des
milliers de roumains répondent à son
appel
premières images de citoyens anonymes de
roumains sans leurs chaînes et de crises
de parole libre et 10 h 10
c'est que l'état tienne watchdata soyons
vigilants attention les hommes de la
milice tente encore partout ceausescu a
plus d'un tour dans son sac
soyons prudents nous ne savons pas
toujours où il est nommé ninja dinescu
rôles nationale mais le miracle est déjà
là dans les milliers de voix qui n'ont
pas oublié le vieil hymne national
roumain
ans
rien n'est vraiment réglé mais tout le
monde sait déjà que grâce à une partie
de l'armée favorables aux manifestants
les terribles miliciens de la securitate
et où pour l'instant céder le terrain
dans le centre de la capitale et on
chante
malgré les rumeurs d'une contre attaque
des partisans de l'ancien dictateur en
direction des locaux de la télévision
qui continue à parler au pays et au
monde et avec la nuit la liberté
naissante tombe en direct à la
télévision roumaine incroyable au siège
de l'ex comité central dans l'ancien
palais royal ils sont des centaines de
milliers à écouter les proclamations du
nouveau conseil national a même
s'adresser à la foule le premier orateur
n'utilise pas le terme tovaritch
camarades mais frappe si fort mes frères
et s'est immédiatement le délire
car tout est plus en position arrive au
balcon un petit homme qui annonce qu'il
est sorti de prison voilà une heure à
peine c'est dimitri m'a t-il ou
diplomates roumains des nations unies
incarcéré pour avoir osé rédiger un vrai
rapport sur les droits de l'homme en
roumanie
il avait disparu depuis tous les
orateurs il va appeler à la prudence au
calme dire non à la vengeance oui à la
modération à la télévision le défilé des
dernières victimes connues de 25 ans de
police politique continue dehors
l'histoire sanglante de la roumanie est
encore en marche
elle n'a fait pour l'instant qu'un trou
dans le drapeau roumain un drapeau ou
les symboles du pouvoir communiste ont
été systématiquement arraché nicolae
ceausescu et sa femme elena ont donc été
arrêtés par l'armée à 70 km au
nord-ouest de bucarest
dès ce matin il avait fui en hélicoptère
puis se sentant pour chasser il avait
changé de moyens de transport il avait
tenté de s'enfuir en voiture cette fois
voici cette course pathétique d'un
dictateur en fuite à travers son pays
encore une perte huissier ce coût a fui
en hélicoptère de bucarest
ils tentent de partir pour la chine le
comité de salut national qui vient de
prendre le pouvoir
'l'annonce à la foule dans un meeting
improvisé la traque du dictateur va
durer une partie de la journée les
dépêches des agences de noront des
informations contradictoires
12h45 nicolae ceausescu et sa femme
d'école du palais présidentiel puis se
pose à l'aéroport de titou aussitôt de
hauts responsables militaires donne
l'ordre à l'armée de se saisir de
l'ancien dictateur sur le point d'être
attrapé il échappe
c'est alors en voiture que le couple
présidentiel et plusieurs de ses
collaborateurs tentent de fuir qu'attend
entrant enfin la radio annonce
l'arrestation de nicolas ceausescu et de
sa femme attire gaulliste et c'est à
dire environ 70 km au nord-ouest de
bucarest
à peine 40 minutes après une dépêche
annonce l'arrestation de nigou ceausescu
leur fils assis bout la ville dont il
était le chef
tout de suite je vous propose un
témoignage ce témoignage c'est il ya
quelques minutes à peine vincent gerard
a pu joindre au téléphone un roumain de
bucarest écouter ce qu'ils nous disaient
le palais présidentiel qu'est ce qui se
passe en france des incidents devant
l'ambassade roumaine à paris des
immigrés roumains ont voulu repousser
des militants du front national qui
voulait reprendre la manifestation alors
qu'on veut les voir sur ces images
résultat il ya eu des affrontements
entre d'une part donc les militants du
front national d'autre part les
imiteront des immigrés roumains qui
manifestaient et il y a eu d'incident
vous voyez assez violent
nous allons voir tout à l'heure dans le
magazine le peuple roumain fait révoltés
parce qu'ils étaient écrasés par une
dictature sans merci avec une
particularité de taille c'est être le
pouvoir absolu d'un homme et de sa
famille rarement sans doute au 20e
siècle
rarement une famille à elle seule à
contrôler le pouvoir dans un pays
pendant si longtemps
michel mompontet le pouvoir aux mains en
une image et une famille éternellement à
la droite de dieu le père elena
ceausescu pour de nombreux roumains
l'esprit de la répression c'est elle
officiellement elle est la plus grande
lumière du monde scientifique roumain
toutes les découvertes dans tous les
domaines et ce depuis 15 ans sont sortis
de son cerveau génial
en fait elle ne signer de son nom les
recherches devraient avant et les
faisait ensuite disparaître
s'appropriant leurs travaux on l'a dit
tellement méfiante que personne ne l'a
jamais vu boire dans un autre verre que
le sien
cette paysanne quasi les traits
prétendez que les roumaines étaient
heureux que dans la crasse elle ne
connaissait c'est vrai que les visions
et les bijoux qu'elle faisait acheter
par ses services secrets derrière maman
le fils aîné nique ou deux patients les
femmes et l'alcool
ces orgies son célèbre à bucarest il
n'avait pas hésité à envoyer les hommes
de sa securitate pour empêcher les
fiançailles de nadia comaneci ce qui
avait eu l'incroyable audace ne se
refuse à lui ils viennent ensuite l es9
frère du conte du 14 au choix il y par
exemple général vice président du comité
de défense passé directement de caporal
à général ou nick holland route à le
chef des services secrets tous choisis
bien sûr seulement sur leurs compétences
et devient enfin les oncles les tantes
et les soeurs tous à des postes clés du
système chercher ce coup rien à redire
pour le génie des carpates la famille
c'est sacré et bien pratique pour
opprimer un peuple
reste cette question à l'issue d'une
journée d'insurrection qui a pris le
pouvoir en roumanie apparemment il y à
au moins deux groupes d'un côté un
comité national pour la démocratie avec
des militaires et des intellectuels et
puis de l'autre un comité de salut
national avec à sa tête cornelio manescu
un ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères
alors georges bortoli pardon qu est-ce
qu on peut en penser qu' elle vraiment
le pouvoir ce soir personne seule archi
gesco vite arrêté son premier ministre à
démissionner donc il ya deux organismes
qui essayent de combler le vide
il y a ce comité pour la démocratie dont
le porte-parole est monsieur dionne
iliescu qui a été longtemps considéré
comme un favori de monsieur ceausescu
puisqu'il celui ci l'avait fait nommer
secrétaire du comité central
mais les choses se sont gâtées et il a
été démis de ses fonctions récemment
et puis il ya un deuxième organisme
alors qu'est ce comité de salut national
qui est d'apparence moins spontané ce
qui ressemble davantage à un
gouvernement provisoire qui est présidée
par quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien en
france qui est monsieur cornelio manescu
qui a été longtemps ambassadeur de
roumanie en france de 77 à 82 exactement
il était déjà en perte de vitesse
jusqu'à 20 ans ils avaient des fonctions
beaucoup plus importante
il était ministre des affaires
étrangères comme tel il représentait
souvent son pays aux nations-unies et
c'est un match de 73 ans avait rallié
ces derniers temps l'opposition en
signant une lettre ouverte à church
escrocs avec cinq autres personnalités
lettre ouverte extrêmement sévère pour
la politique du dictateur
voilà ce qu'on peut rappeler encore d'un
moment ça c'est le rôle éminent de
l'armée ce sont des généraux qui ont
donné l'ordre d'arrêter de chercher ce
coup c'est un général celui qui commande
là le schéma mais qui a fait masser ses
troupes autour de l'immeuble de la
radio-télévision pour le protéger contre
une contre attaque c'est encore le chef
d'état major qui annonçait que la police
politique était en principe 10 août et
que ses troupes étaient en principe
subordonné au trot du ministère de la
défense me paraît plus facile à dire
qu'à faire parce que les troupes du
ministère de la défense sont 180 mille
âmes et les troupes spéciales les
troupes de la sécurité politique sont 80
mille sont très nombreuses en plus et
les professionnels donc c'est l'anarchie
dans cette anarchie les militaires les
vrais militaires passés de la sécurité
ceux du nid sur la défense paraît s'être
rallié dans leur quasi totalité à la
révolution
ils vont sûrement avoir un rôle à jouer
dans les jours qui viennent merci
georges les réactions maintenant elles
viennent du monde entier
la cee les 12 pays de l'europe ils ont
fait part dès ce matin de leur volonté
d'apporter à la roumanie
l'aide immédiate et la coopération dont
l'avait privé le régime ceausescu
washington
bien sûr se félicite du changement et
plus important encore la réaction de
moscou
tout à l'heure michael gorbatchev a fait
adopter au député d'union soviétique une
résolution pour soutenir la juste cause
du peuple roumain
peu de temps avant les députés avaient
applaudi à tout rompre lorsque monsieur
gorbatchev leur avait annoncé
l'arrestation du dictateur chassé
seconde réaction en france aussi de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche on
se réjouit une unité rarissime exemple
jean marie le pen se félicite du
soulèvement héroïque du peuple roumain
et puis à l'autre bout de l'échiquier le
parti communiste il n'hésite pas à se
réjouir lui aussi de la destitution de
ceausescu
ce même parti communiste français qu'il
y à trois semaines n'avait pas hésité à
envoyer un de ses représentants pour
assister au congrès du pc aux mains
lorsque ce congrès a clamé encore chat
ou ses scoops
enfin le président mitterrand il y a
deux heures à peine à exprimer son
sentiment sur la roumanie c'était vous
allez le voir à l'issue de la conférence
euro arabe
je pense que vous savez que notre
rencontre prend place un moment où des
événements à la signification
exceptionnel se déroule pas en europe de
l'est que l'ordre ancien issu de la
deuxième guerre mondiale qui nous
étaient devenus familiers se trouvent
remises en cause
sous l'effet d'une formidable aspiration
à la liberté peut interpréter ces
événements de façon très différentes
mais toutes les interprétations se
ramène à une essentielle c'est une
victoire de la liberté voilà avant de
passer au reste de l'actualité
rapidement de cette journée nous allons
tout de suite revenir philippe lefait
avec vous sur les dernières informations
en provenance de bucarest
avez vous du nouveau et bien écoutez on
a des images et en tout cas des images
de qui se plaint d une scène qui se
passe à l heure actuelle il se confirme
que depuis 17h heure de paris
il y à des tirs dans les rues de
bucarest entre l'armée qui s'est rallié
aux manifestants est également
les militaires qui sont restés fidèles à
chercher ce coup des unités spéciales de
chercher secours sont décrites comme
faisant route actuellement vers la
capitale roumaine de plastique est une
ville qui se trouve à 60 km de bucarest
elle ferait route vers le centre ville
et également vers l'aéroport à l'instant
la chaîne de télévision roumaine appelle
les roumains à se battre jusqu'à la
dernière goutte de sang et à combattre
les meurtriers je cite l'agent
soviétique tu as qui a donné beaucoup
d'informations sur les événements ces
dernières 24 heures fait également état
de combats et on signale également que
l'immeuble des archives à bucarest
serait en flammes à l'instant radio
sofia qui est la radio bulgare annonce
que l'ancien palais royal qui sert
aujourd'hui de siège au comité central
serait en flammes
enfin le correspondant de la radio
hongroise parle de combats de rue
voilà les combats dre je crois à
philippe nous allons les voir tout de
suite sur des images d'une fusillade que
nous venons de recevoir justement
c'était fabuleux car est il y à quelques
minutes tout de suite nous allons les
voir ces images
voilà un bilan philippe et apparemment
la radio et la télévision roumaine qui
ont été libérés qui donc que sont passés
dans le camp des anti chasse est secouée
par la l'instant 200 morts c'est
apparemment un bilan qui est confirmé
par la radio bulgare sont morts donc
merci philippe oui je prends le
téléphone voilà alors maintenant nous
allons dans un instant bien sûr nous
allons retrouver daniel bilalian pour
une page spéciale d'une heure consacrée
à la roumanie mais tout de même nous
allons voir tout de suite le reste de
l'actualité
maintenant nous allons le voir avec i'm
consignes et en commençant par panama où
là encore un dictateur est en fuite mais
cette fois le général noriega n'a pas
été rattrapé tout de suite donc les
autres informations de l'actualité de ce
jour poursuite des combats aujourd'hui
dans la capitale et la ville de david et
forces loyalistes lance ce soir une
contre attaque sur le quartier général
des forces américaines à fana m'a
clairement endara élu président en mai
dernier a officiellement pris le pouvoir
et instauré le couvre feu
il affirme que l'absence de noriega
n'empêchera pas la mise en place d'un
nouveau gouvernement
aux etats unis les cordes et 20 soldats
tués au panama ont été rapatriés et
l'espagne demande des explications sur
la mort de ce journaliste d'el país
cuillère par une balle américaine
à augusto pinochet ne quittera pas le
commandement des forces armées
chiliennes
aujourd'hui son successeur à la
présidence patricio aylwin lui demander
au cours d'une entrevue de démissionner
de ce poste en mars prochain date de la
passation de pouvoir entre les deux
hommes
signature ce matin d'un accord entre les
patrons de journaux et le syndicat du
livre cgt fapt d'une semaine de conflit
et de 23 heures de négociations au siège
des nouvelles messageries de la presse
parisienne
selon cet accord la cgt accepte la
modernisation des nmpp
en contrepartie les personnels des
ouvriers de la presse au sein de vos une
prime annuelle de 6000 francs accord
syndicats-patronat sur une nouvelle
convention d'assurance chômage valable
pour trois ans les changements
revalorisation des allocations des
chômeurs en fin de droit ainsi que des
chômeurs en formation et fès les
cotisations points 0,12 pour cent et
première depuis 62 annulation par le
conseil d'état de l'élection de michel
mouillot à la mairie de cannes
selon le conseil les résultats du vote
ont été faussées par la distribution
juste avant le scrutin
deux tracés injurieux à l'égard de mme
anne-marie vue puis candidate rpr